do you remember
[Music]
great disasters where things just went
great disasters or by great i just mean
absolute things going on things going
awry
the rails certainly nothing with conan
oh there was that breaking i mean the
beer the oh that's a good one okay but
that never i mean we never
we conan was going to visit sam adams
sam adams and boston do we talk about
ever talk about it sounds familiar but
what happened well he tore that he told
the brewery yes and we were going to go
into where they developed new beers yeah
and they're like you know we have this
this really fancy uh area in the the lab
where they're a lab like a testing lab
it's a testing lab and they're all these
guys in robes
and there's 28
uh
taps
so we had an idea oh
what
let's
like conan creates his own blend
from the 28 taps so we're like let's
build a contraption that we stick on all
the track on all the taps 28 taps and it
all comes into one funnel
and and and our special effects guys
casey noel yes bill built this thing and
john
brought it and set it up and we had a
bar of wood that would
lower all the taps
yeah all 28. and so we're like let's
let's test it out you know this is like
we weren't coming wasn't there yet the
first time you're supposed to happen
ended up getting canceled so we were
there like let's just test this out
right let's test out so it's you me and
uh john rau yeah and uh
and you're just shooting it on the
iphone and so we were like okay and i
was holding
i had a picture
a small picture oh boy like you would
get it like a fridays of water or sprite
or something
and we're like this is going to be fun
you know so and we're like let it rip
and and
the bark the bar comes down and within
one eighth of a second my video is
horrendous because
once i see what's happening i'm just
dying one eighth of a second
oh it just
immediately overflowed and was just
gushing
and really like okay shut down shut down
like a fire hydrant but like we shut the
bar back it's still it's still so many
people like five minutes and we just
we're crying and we turn around and
there are twenties
there are twelve and they're coats and
they're professionals
and we're laughing crying oh my god
crying you were like i immediately went
down i couldn't ever just look down to
the floor but then i come back up and i
just see your face and your faces yeah
because the volume of liquid that's
coming out yeah so much pouring out the
most is so forceful like a five-year-old
would be like well you're not gonna you
should not do this you're not gonna open
28 taps at once right
force them into one small tube
to a five-year-old
not us the idea that we were going to
get it all in that thing was ridiculous
we had no backup basins
but then we're like
we had a powwow outside like well so do
we still give it another treat yeah like
maybe we just gotta tweak it a little
bit yeah you know
because someone spent oh my god hours
and hours building it was an all this 28
it was like you know mile of tubing and
all these
brass fixtures connecting everything i
remember john cohen was like so this is
not going to work do i need to bring
this back he's like toss it yeah
you mean the 28 tap tube thing yeah no
leave it there we have a gift for salmon